Wow this pandemic has really knocked us off our feet, hasn't it?
Before the pandemic, there was talk of the car industry's demise.
People were going to only be doing ride sharing and car sharing.
The days of personal vehicle ownership were absolutely gone.
And people were writing the epitaph on the gravestone of the car industry.
I think this time frame has really shifted that somewhat.
I think it's made us aware that we have to somewhat be dependent on ourselves.
Although it's so fantastic to live in a society where we're sharing things.
We're information sharing, we're asset sharing.
There still has to be some self-reliance.
And I don't know about you but I probably wouldn't get in an Uber right now.
I'm sure that the Uber drivers are doing an amazing job...
...and that they're all masked and that they're keeping their cars clean and safe.
I am 100% sure of that.
But it's a personal preference...
...and right now I prefer to be in control of my own destiny in my own car...
...where I know that I've sanitized it and I know that who's been in and out of it.
So I still think there's absolutely going to be room for car sharing...
...and for other kinds of sharing like that.
But I still think it's important that we have a car of our own...
...somewhere in our family so that we can control our own destiny.